my name is gumo i'm i'm a hacker
i've been a hacker for the past 36 years
and i'm here to tell my story
my story started
pretty um
pretty young right i was born and raised
in jacksonville florida
grew up
absolutely dirt poor
and
i had an older brother i had two older
brothers one half brother and a natural
sibling
and all of us grew up
in jacksonville growing up in
jacksonville
uh
you know
we we were
we only had a mom our mother
she raised us by herself all three of us
the best bet the best that she could
uh she was um
she was an alcoholic
and uh she did the best raising three
boys
uh
[Applause]
my mom passed away when i was 12 years
old in 1985
and
i actually
actually woke up on december the 7th
1985 and
pulled the covers back and uh there was
my mom
uh and so
uh
ever ever since then i've been on my own
um my brother and i we went to go live
with
my aunt but she failed at that miserably
and my father was in prison
so there was no choice really but to
live with friends of the family which
which we did
uh for a little while
and
uh my brother uh
he was about a year and a half older
than me so he was
much more the free spirit and uh so he
he uh he just went on went on his way um
went on to
do his thing
at 16 years old
by that time i i'm 14 and a half and you
know really on my own
and that's when i discovered computers
right
actually i discovered computers about
three years earlier before my mother
passed away
uh never really
gave any consideration to it other than
you know any other normal kid at
at uh
at the age of eight nine ten
so it sat
until my mother passed away and
before she passed away the night that
the night actually that she passed away
she had come home
from graduation on my brother my half
brother had graduated
basic training at fort benning
and
the the thing she told me before she
went to bed was uh she asked me how my
my computer studies were coming along
and um i lied to her right and i said
they were going great
uh you know actuality i really wasn't
doing anything
um then she passed right and then
i
i um
you know you deal with what you can deal
with when when you're you know 12 13
years old and
my outlet was computers
uh first
you know withdrew like any other kid
does
uh i guess i don't know uh and second of
all i um
i began to master my computer i had a
trs-80 model too
and i taught myself to uh i taught
myself how to code uh
code basic
and um
for a couple years that's where that's
where i i was right when when people
would ask me if i was fine yeah i'm fine
yeah but you know
my grades were really disastrous um
you know i had a couple friends that i
really engaged with but no one two in
particular
but i did withdraw i did withdraw even
more into my computer right that uh i i
got an acoustical modem
connected that uh to a local bulletin
board
and begin to meet other people begin to
meet other people like me um and then
you know
people ask about you right you know they
they want to know who you are and you
know
back then
the internet was the internet really
wasn't what people think it is now it
was
more or less
dial-up boards uh arpanet
uh closed-loop systems such as
things of that such
uh and but
uh i set up a bulletin board uh on a
local bbs system uh and uh at at the
ripe old age of uh 14. i started to meet
other other hackers online
uh and i i started to learn a lot of uh
cool things like um like telephone
freaking like how to make free phone
calls um
i discovered a subculture of people who
existed on the phone lines on the
telephone lines where they where you
could talk to someone
uh you know in in in london or in in
paris or in georgia or l.a
and
you can meet these people on on the
telephone on the the these telephone
um
party lines so to speak and
so that was so um
you know 14 years old i'm learning how
to freak telephone systems uh freaking
telephone systems was a way to actually
access the old
telephone systems the old bell systems
with special instructions and codes and
and and
methods uh which are which have long
since
expired
since
the telephone system has
gone digital but
um
so 14 years old i'm learning you know
i'm learning how to
uh
you know code myself i've set up a
bulletin board i'm meeting hackers and
i'm getting advice i'm learning how to
do things i'm learning how to
get the things that i need right because
i'm living with friends of the family
and they really
you know they
they too themselves were barely able to
support me
uh
much
barely themselves as well so
i everything that i had to do was for
myself right um everything um
from food to money for for money for
clothes for school um
everything
my entire existence depended on my
willingness to make sure that i was
taking care of myself
and so
that's what i learned how to do i
learned how to
at the age of 15 years old i took a bell
and howl language master and i i learned
how to
reprogram credit cards
uh to use them
in stores and and um and atms
back before atms really
had a dedicated atm line to verify that
a transaction
um
and of course i would understand the
batching process and all that um but
those that was that was 32 years ago
and i just learned how to manipulate
things to get the things that i wanted
uh whether it was printing a a upc code
for food for from the store which i
needed
or doing the uh the the
the magnetic gas handle flip back in
those days uh when you needed gas for
your car
there was a dial on the on the gas pump
and you would flip the dial on and off
well if you were to take if you took a
sp an old-fashioned speaker magnet and
set it next to the the handle that would
flip it up and engage the pump the pump
would begin to run
to distribute gas in in the hose but it
would the numbers wouldn't turn
and so that was uh so i kept learning
these tricks right i kept learning
little tricks to survive survivor
ability tricks
learning how to social engineer people
um
to get what i wanted uh whether
it was access to a specific
computer that i wanted to dial in to
steal some files from or whether or not
it was to convince the
supermarket manager that i'd actually
had left some food behind when in turn i
actually hadn't just so i could eat that
night
um
so you know just growing up letting
meeting hackers
on the online people
people giving me uh what i felt like was
worthwhile advice to survive to
to be able to
you know not not wind up in a bad
situation
uh and that's um
that's exactly how i i kept my uh myself
from
uh falling apart from going under um
living with in all all of the while
right i'm still living with uh friends
of the family
1989 comes around i'm
i'm 16 17 years old
the friends of the family really had
enough of me
living there so
the official
parting of ways right so there i am i
just turned 17 years old and i'm on my
own um i have a uh
i had a chevrolet chevette a 1984
chevrolet event no in 1982 chevrolet
chevette powder blue and all of my stuff
was in there and including including my
trs-80 model too
and
i i went uh i lived in my car for
for um
for the better part of the entire year
of 1989
and
it was tough right it was uh you know i
dropped out of school
i i began to lose focus i i began
uh began stealing cars began
using my skills in very very unique
fashions to obtain money quickly
because when you're living in your car
what choice do you have
um
so yeah i did that for about a year
and
then then i met
then then i met a girl
and
she became my girlfriend
and ultimately she became a wife
and
she helped me she helped me realize what
what i was capable
of
of doing
and um
her family took me in
and um
i went and
i went and got hurt
we got a job you know just bagging
groceries and [ __ ]
and um
just kept doing that right you know
someone someone believed in me you know
and uh
still sticking to computers
uh
i had a daughter my daughter who turns
30
this december
my daughter my wife and i had a daughter
and uh i i realized that uh you know i
needed to
needed to do better needed to do more
provide more
for um
for my wife and my daughter and so
uh there i am bagging groceries
um
working working in retail stores
uh and actually
working hard and continuing my computer
studies teaching myself
how uh c uh cobalt fortran all of the
old languages teaching myself computer
languages
uh and
taking care of a wife and a kid on five
dollars an hour and uh
kept doing that and
about uh about two years into that i got
the opportunity i saved up enough money
to go um to the chaos congress in
germany
which
is an annual conference of hackers from
all around the world
and um
i i met some some
some some
hackers like me who
had uh who had
not only been through a struggle but
were continuing to go to a struggle and
uh
i met i met a good i met he i met a
friend of mine his name was boris florik
he went by the hacker named tron
and we became really good friends
and um
boris and i we we worked on a lot of
smart card systems together he taught me
about smart cards that the little chip
card in your wallet that everyone
carries around
you know that thing what's in your
wallet um
and at the time no one really knew what
smart cards were they were only used
extensively in europe
at the time
and so boris taught me about smart cards
these things that have a computer and
microprocessor in them
and
he taught me that these things control
many things from
um
from television
access to telephone access to
making and receiving long distance calls
and so we worked on a crypto card scheme
together to where we were able to
actually reverse engineer
about
five different providers
who issued
chip card smart cards for their services
we successfully decrypted those services
and with that knowledge
um
you know after we became friends um
after
a couple years
um
we
we began to converse back and forth uh
you know at that at that point this is
94
and
uh now i'm attending uh the chaos
congress each year
and uh meeting with boris and we're
we're chatting back and forth on uh this
all kinds of technology
most specifically
smart cards
about that time here in the united
states
[Music]
hughes space systems
was ready to launch a system called
directv
um back then actually was called
dss the digital satellite system
and and
hughes built the system from the ground
up
uh and i was interested in that uh the
reason i was interested in that because
at
this point it's 1995 my father has just
been released from prison and so i go to
visit him and he's watching television i
said oh dad what is that he's like oh
it's a satellite system called directv
and i was amazed by the the picture
quality and and how
how great it looked and and it all came
on a little small 18 inch dish
so that that was pretty fascinating and
and i i looked at the system and and i'd
i'd realized that was um
it was it was controlled all of the
authorizations were controlled by you
know you guessed it a smart card
uh so i it really took very little to no
effort between boris and i to
collaborate on
the directvf card which basically was
a smart card that allowed authorization
for customers to receive hbo all of the
channels right pay-per-views etc
and um
we successfully created a a quite little
humble system to reprogram those cards
and um
yeah
laughed it off uh really didn't think
anything of the wearers after that
uh and then several months passed right
a busy busy couple years i'm going
i'm going to school uh and
and actually um working at a uh at a
carpet cleaning company
and um just really just surviving paying
the bills and continuing to enhance my
skills
and um
i'm like well you know the hell would it
you know let's i really need some more
money you know my daughter's
getting ready to go into
school and so i wanted to put her into
school
and so i i decided to sell my wares for
programming directv satellite access
cards and so that's what i did
i
i realized that it was
very easy to make money
doing doing providing a service for
people who did not wish to pay their
bill
uh so i really i really tried to i
really wanted to one-up my game right so
uh boris and i we worked together on
some
extensible ideas and uh
we created some software that we sold to
the canadians um
and uh we
we made some money right we made um
we made you know 10 million dollars each
and i was able to get everything that i
wanted
uh and so did boris uh and
it was great but uh
there was there were a lot more factors
than just boris and i releasing code
there were other
mitigating factors you had an entire
battalion of hackers from rupert
murdoch's end
trying to actually circumvent
other services and competitors out there
uh to destroy them which they ultimately
did
but that's a whole other story so
uh
hacked direct tv for a few years uh and
made some money went to uh got caught um
and then uh
after i got caught i was uh
i was offered offered an opportunity
right uh rather than to
go and sit in prison for a
long time
i was asked to consult in helping a
company at that time called nds
to help them solve their conditional
access problem which at that point
you know their entire
the entire directv system was completely
compromised um
and
nds was looking for a way to um
close stamp out piracy so
consulted with uh
some good minds uh in haifa israel for a
couple years and went on my way
came back to jacksonville uh
after hanging out consulting
securing the the directv period 4 card
helping helping
a lot
with that technology
moving on uh
coming back home
my name sort of floated out in the wrong
direction uh this
this uh
guy who was uh doing the direct tv cards
he his wife was a um
a dispatcher and and she was she had
actually she had she obtained my
information
uh and then my wife's information and
then
my family's information and and and
pretty much doxxed me at that point and
back then
doxing someone was really uh a
terrifying thing as such it is now right
when when someone doxes you and posts
your information on the internet uh it's
it's a shitty thing to go through and
um in my in my circumstance i had a lot
of um
a lot more
a lot more
things that i was involved with with the
government so um
with with a lot of help from the
government
and my own self
my self motivation now it was time
i moved i moved to indiana
um packed up the kids uh packed
everything and moved to indiana
uh it's just gonna really kind of lay
low for a while um you know i just got
back from israel
i moved from florida to indiana
and really just kind of
you know chilled out i got a little job
i got a job at a newspaper
and
you know handled their websites and all
of that real low-key reload tech job
nothing fancy living in the middle of a
corn field so to speak and
and uh enjoyed it enjoyed the life uh
for a couple years
and then i was asked to
and then
a gentleman i met in indiana
invited me up to chicago to
take a look at his business to see
what sort of technical advice i could
give him for his business and so
i traveled to chicago
sort of got to know him
within several days
he got to know who i really was about my
my background
and
i went to work for him
and
uh
at this point right you know now i have
a job and he's done
and i'm doing um
i'm setting up
you know i.t infrastructure for his
company and
and
making sure that
all of his offices connect
and not only that but securely right
cyber security really wasn't a thing
then
uh it it was barely even mentioned
um but you know
but cyber security to me right to what
exists now or what people realize that
cyber security
now
to me is just an afterthought or was an
afterthought still sort of is
mentally speaking
um because
you know things that people are writing
papers about talking about creating
solutions about um
these are all things that um
are built on technologies that were
built when the internet uh was created
right your everybody's you know talking
about 1970s technology
and no one's really trying to fix the
problem
uh but uh
yeah so i provided cyber security uh for
him his company
set up the whole deal
um
and then just started meeting new
friends along the way in chicago uh
that's how it is in chicago um
and uh one thing led to another
i met a gentleman named willard harper
willard buddy harper
uh and he um he worked at the uh cme in
chicago
he was one of the uh largest hog traders
in um
in the world really
and he gave me an opportunity to
create some special networks for the cme
uh to connect to the nyse
and so with that after doing several of
those you know meaning you know they
were really simple for me but i created
some
ultra high speed private networks that
only the cme and the nyse um still use
and so he was impressed with that and
he's like what else can you do and i'm
like so people know the chicago
mercantile exchange and the new york
stock exchange that is correct yes yeah
so i set up um two bi-directional uh
unique fiber lines um
specifically for those two exchanges and
secure them
so yeah he asked me what was next
uh so i'm like hey there's this thing
called bitcoin uh i'm kind of it kind of
piques my interest and
uh he asked me what i needed uh
i said you know
about a million bucks would work and he
literally opened up a file cabinet it
had a million dollars and it's like all
right
go to it and um that's what i did uh at
that point i built uh i built a
supercomputer that was able to mine
bitcoin
uh at mined about 5000 bitcoin and at
that point i believe they were bitcoin
was trading at 200 to 300 a coin
and so he was impressed and so was i
actually and so we built three more over
the next eight months i built three more
uh and had them right there at 107 west
van buren street uh across from the cme
uh and just sucking up electricity um
but uh at the at the end of that year
and a half run
uh we were able to mine uh close to 80
000 bitcoin
so yeah i kind of uh
kind of you know after a couple years of
doing that it really felt uh
a little a little sense of
accomplishment but i really didn't feel
like it was done
so i ran into a gentleman um
so i'm just kind of i'm squandering
around chicago right i've made you know
some bitcoin you know i'm hanging out
you know walking around the loop you
know hanging out in millennial park and
just hanging out with my friends uh and
it kind of kicking back and i met a
gentleman
and he said hey you know
our company needs a webmaster right and
a webmaster is just basically someone
who
just does web work for a company i'm
like
okay yeah sure yeah i'll come and be
your webmaster right because
having a job having a legitimate job
completes who i am right i could sit
around and
and do whatever i want to make money but
in the end i think it's about working an
honest 905 and so yeah yeah hey jackson
i'll go and work you be a webmaster at
your software company and so i went to
work there uh
as their webmaster and it was it was
hilarious right they're they're they're
vice presidents they're like well this
is a very important job and you should
blah blah blah
yes sir and you know and and uh yes
ma'am and
and i really kept the ruse up as long as
i could but uh i was outed by um
a friend of mine uh that worked there um
and uh he outed me to the marketing
manager and the marketing manager she
outed me to the entire staff and
eventually i became
responsible for their cyber security
practice and so i'm like well [ __ ] i
guess i'm doing cyber security so here i
am
doing cyber security for a software
company in chicago unintended rights but
honing my skills right figuring out um
figuring out the best method for
to to
stand up uh specific
protocols and systems and and
things of that nature from a cyber
security perspective and so
uh that's what i did and i did it pretty
well
um
but uh then they fired me uh then they
just they fired me and so uh
yeah it was kind of a thing between the
owner and myself uh he didn't like me
and i surely didn't like him so now that
that's public i really didn't like him
um
so after that right uh i just uh took a
couple gigs as cyber security um
you know just kind of uh
you know just did my thing packed up my
stuff the entire time in chicago
and
came back to jacksonville and uh
again you know i'm doing consulting with
the company for cyber security and i
enjoy it
but um
the that that's what led me to where i
am now right from from some of those
angles
i've been responsible for putting some
heavy hitters
away i've worked with law enforcement
uh in in the past
some real heavy hitters uh
they you know uh i'm really good at
hunting hackers and finding people
and finding and not finding
not finding just people just but finding
the real the real the real hacker right
the real hacker that's really causing
him i'm that guy that looks for that
hacker and
i do that i do that very seriously and
continue to do that because
i provide my service not only for
companies right but for
uh celebrities and and stars right they
they consult with me i i i work with
them personally
uh and uh to solve any cyber security
questions or issues that they have you
know some of the some of the things that
people don't understand is
that everyone carries around a
smartphone you know watching watching
edward snowden you know do all of this
ridiculousness hiding under covers and
everything everyone should know that
your smartphone is is a pc is a portable
computer and the things that that
smartphones are capable of doing
are are
are very terrifying um there there just
recently was
an exploit that i had used for years for
ios
that allowed me to actually listen in on
your phone conversations to read your
sms messages to read your email to
actually see everything that you do on
your ios device
um
and those those those sort of those sort
of exploits exists
everywhere
in everything almost everything has
a gps chip in it almost every device has
a chip in it and if it has a chip in it
it can be exploited and when when things
are exploited sometimes things devices
things systems and people are exploited
for one reason or another
you know there's
there's a lot of things that are very
scary out there
there there are right now there's there
are
people selling your information they are
selling your they are selling your wi-fi
network they're selling your wi-fi
credentials they're selling your
ancestry.com
genealogy
you know data they're selling all of
that there's
the the thing that people don't really
understand is that
there really is no more privacy in this
world
uh unless you go and live on an island
somewhere in the south pacific with no
electricity and no other people
there there are things to be taken
advantage of in systems and devices and
and so on
you know
it takes it takes a a professional car
thief about 30 seconds to steal a car
now
because you really don't need to
hot wire anything or use a screwdriver
or even a laptop you can use
an rf interceptor intercepting device
which could do a man-in-the-middle
attack with just a key fob and you can
steal someone's you know 150 000 car
with that
there there
the the technology stacks out there are
endless to that are being taken
advantage of
most most notably are the cellular
systems the the mobile systems what
people care around most are
contain the most value and the most data
putting your information on putting your
information on tick tock you know
creating a tick tock account and and and
filming from so many locations
you don't realize what you're really
doing is you're really you're really
giving
everything that you you hold possessive
and private out to the world and that's
where we see people being attacked
people being um their their bank
accounts being compromised etc
speaking of bank accounts a lot of
people realize that
you know that when you log into your
bank and a lot of banks will really deny
this
but banks actually have back doors into
their in into your accounts into your
system just think about it for a moment
you log in to your bank accounts
you know through such and such dot com
and you have to answer all of these
ridiculous questions and get a
two-factor sms message sent to you so
you can enter in the code
but people really don't realize is that
their
banks also have backdoor access to where
applications like your turbo tax and
your your your your
money
management software all of that how do
you think that connects to your banks
and so
with these backdoor connections into
banks
uh things continue to be in inherently
insecure
um you we see data breaches every day
where millions of people have their
information stolen
and not only stolen but
you know sold
and
used against them
uh
one of the one of the things that we
also have to realize is that we have
quantum computers coming
quantum computers will make all current
and former encryption algorithms
absolutely obsolete
so if you have something that you've
encrypted in the past or you have some
encrypted files
and they've been
anywhere on the internet in a book
wherever someone else can access your
encrypted files
well very soon those files won't remain
encrypted long and so hopefully
you know your those uh
those secrets were quite well encrypted
websites websites have so many flaws in
them
if you go everybody needs a website
nowadays everybody has a website to go
to their favorite website
right now about 90 percent of the the
web
and the technologies that support them
in your applications and websites
they're they're insecure they're
inherently insecure
whether or not it's a web server running
an open port or a
misconfigured
file on your server
there's something that
there's there's there's a little bit of
something out there for everyone to take
advantage of
and there's
and now everyone is paying the price
everyone now is becoming victims to
these crimes to where they thought they
weren't a victim uh they where they
never thought that they would actually
be potentially be a victim
um
you know the more mobile applications
the more people that are using the
phones that we just you know the more
more people that use mobile devices
require more mobile applications require
more more data centers require more
servers for those applications to
connect to
and those are all at risk
you know it it really
all you have to do is you know do a dns
query on anyone's web domain and you can
begin to uncover the pieces of of how
insecure most organizations
and individuals are
uh people don't realize that uh they are
you know when they're at home they they
put a password on their their router and
they think that's it that's you know i'm
safe i'm secure but no one
no one really
understands the context of
you know using an additional layer of
protection like a vpn
or or some sort of ad blocking
technology
and
and people don't realize that their ip
address is is basically like a flag out
there on the internet for them
and for them to be discovered for them
to be stalked harassed intimidated uh
swatted it doesn't matter
and so
it all comes it all comes with uh
understanding you know these these
technologies and understanding how to
protect ourselves and how to protect
yourself
against bad people
wearing hoodies and cloaks
as i said not all hackers are bad people
[Music]
most hackers
everyone is a hacker if it weren't for
hackers we would not have wi-fi we
wouldn't have cameras we wouldn't have
many things that we take
for granted today
criminals are the ones that give hackers
of bad names criminals are the ones who
are breaking into systems and stealing
information and creating data breaches
criminals are the ones who are stalking
people
and bad contacts and stealing from
others who don't who don't belong
not hackers
and so
you know it's been said before
and here i am saying it too right
hackers are not bad people
the criminals are bad people but hackers
and no
my thing now right is to
to tell my story to tell people that you
know hackers really aren't bad people
hackers really have
a story to tell too
you know i i have a story to tell and
i'm telling it and i'm almost done
telling it
but
you know we're just like anyone else we
we
we live we breathe
we we have feelings we we actually we
actually over indulge in our feelings
because
we wonder what people are always doing
and what the next best thing is
you know i um
painted my my pinky pink back in 2006
because
a friend of mine i was visiting a friend
of mine in uh in fort myers and
her daughter came and tugged on me she
said hey
why are you such a bad hacker why don't
you be a good hacker and do good things
and ever since then man you know i've
advocated for doing good things with
your skills
helping people
helping others you know not not doing
something for yourself doing something
for others making sure that
making sure that you know your mom and
dad wakes up in the morning without
their [ __ ] being
you know sold on a dark market
and to help
and
to help people right to help people
achieve their goals to help people
understand who they are not just by
where they've been
or what they've seen in the [ __ ] that
they've been through but to under to
help people understand how to get to
where they're going by
telling them what what i've been through
the [ __ ] that i've been through
you know i've been through some real
serious [ __ ] in my life
but that that's never deterred me from
becoming who i am and who i expect
to be and it really hasn't stopped me
from helping others and and showing
other people the way
you know with this pink with this pink
pinky nail now
you know that young lady just got
married this year
and that's that's my goal right to help
as many
ladies as many women as as many females
getting get into cyber security to to
it's not just a guy's thing it's just
not where a sausage fest of guys walking
around saying they hack something it's
about people who are critical thinkers
who contribute who care and have empathy
and share their knowledge that's what
it's about and that's what i'm here to
help people understand and to help
people and encourage people
to do with their skills
yeah man um
i've seen a lot
i've been through a lot i i have my jump
bag right here
with with my bitcoin collection on them
and i'll show mark after
but
the only thing that the only thing that
i can encourage people to do is never
give up always hold your head high
and never ever ever
ever consider giving up no matter how
tough things may get because one way or
another you'll find a way you'll find a
path
and so
hopefully what i've said hopefully my
story helps i don't know
but
if it reaches one person and it gives
someone
that motivation to say hey you know
i can do that too you know i get from
living in cars to consulting with
you know
celebrities and and governments
you know
well then you can do it too so
there's nothing that you can't do
there's nothing that we can't do it's
only it's only about what you choose to
do and the decisions that we all make
and so i choose to do the right thing i
choose to make the right decisions and i
choose to make
the right call and so
that's my story
all right thank you
thanks
you